last week the kids and I finished up their Greek mythology unit
so we decided to end it with an ancient Greek feast
now I love a theme dinner
this is one of my favourite things that I do with the kids
and it just so happened that they love Greek food
so this was actually my favourite one we've done in a while
I set the table in the colours of the Greek flag
and used busts and columns and gold
to kind of bring together this whole ancient Greek
opulent dinner we did about a week of a Greek mythology unit
starting with the chaos and the origin story of Greek mythology
then moving on to learning about the Titans
Cronus and Raya and the story of Zeus and the Titanami key
basically
Greek mythology is a perfect unit for kids who already like action and adventure
for dinner I made a spiced roasted lamb and a Greek Orza salad
and complimented all of that with pita and dips
and the grape leaves and cucumber
there was a little something for everyone and they all enjoyed the meal
had to have a little picture of Dionysus there
I heard he got in a little bit of trouble at the Olympic opening ceremony
but he was a welcome guest at our table this unit was such a